this fence is operated he loses it know
what to play but itself if he operated
these austere patients pain hammerboy
the bats love that whoa razor you have
to elevate don't for the dunk attempt by
calm calm take his car well poke it gets
an opportunity for a three-point play in
the corner is Van Fleet hears dd cream
for the way point five on the clock what
a play call at the end
Danny Green delivers in the Toronto
Raptors leave Orlando with a win but
they dug in defensively and Danny Green
with 0.5 on the clock makers working
laughing what are you still your hide
one I tell you something hey how about
mess up my percentage I'm drilling this
lone ball kcp the only offense
[Applause]
that's stepping up big time down the
stretch of this ballgame that's
impressive right into last couple years
he just didn't feel comfortable let's
this LeBrons been a big help his team
skips the steal gives it up and fake
Thompson was not going to get LeBron
that one back pull it away the eighth
turnover chase down denial ball that
everybody was digging in nobody quits on
plays as a result easy buckets the other
way pockets the play he had to alter
that one because Jackson did a good job
of challenges they can steal break on
Stephenson he's gonna give it up off the
balls Oh Showtime
VanFleet to Ibaka block by Dell there's
cook ahead of the pack one man to beat
gets inside blocked by Danny Green
since say still recovering Maori in a
fan join
on the great block from green DeSoto by
the way looking for their first road win
of the season they're only six and
forties
shooting the three-ball well in like
England what Ingram did that was yeah
I'm glad he got bigger fitness fan
great job by Green
driving kicking green the thread
get down here good hands by Danny Green
whipped up hauled off to cry Leonard he
knows where his party to San Antonio is
right there and you talk about a guy's
gonna make that show cheap not doubt
short for caldwell-pope long lead for
Grayson
could not get out of bounds the ball not
to hustle back after they miss but kcp
did a great job of getting back and just
preventing an easy dude falls moving
he's getting easy quick touches so he
should be getting to the lunch
here's Jimbo Walker off the bat denied
by green then he just knows where to be
look at he's nowhere in the picture here
and all of a sudden boom there he is
he comes up and still with the dribble
with five with four Brandon Smith kicks
it out Stephenson in the corner fly a
three at the buzzer for the Lakers who
got it away before did he take his time
and knock it down whoa Plumlee up in the
third row and three points for kcp can
we get in that I think you feel like a
stage name rights as every pass sort
away by
Danny great seconds to get it done here
he goes behind the back the brought all
the way dishes
[Music]
both fans and I think because of their
defensive presence they've protected the
ball in in the top teams or top
categories
Green working on curry made himself a
little space and knocked it down I just
never seen him post up with the hands of
LeBron or rebound number 12 on the
bounce as to a cutting KC feed for a
three-point opportunity that's just bad
defense even the shot clock for grain
well defended by curry oh boy
makes a tough shot nonetheless
[Music]
he was up there I was a man here at this
duncan whatever the kcp make some pay
and that is the first three of the game
salon right outside Danny Green and a
three beats the buzzer with a triple you
can't leave him for a second time by
going was oppa who did that job last
night on Kendall Walker held him to four
points caldwell-pope splashes from the
outside weak shot able to reel it in and
as Sergio Scavo Yolo mention Danny Green
facts from the cr1
come on give me two right there how
about sandy green coming down bearing
the freight to 20 wins before Christmas
to beat the buzzer that was to beat the
shot clock clock buzzer one extra pass
and kcp gets it up in time and drills
two three so the Lakers go ahead to the
fourth with a three-point advantage
[Applause]
easy peasy just I love boats
it's the handoff robber if it's
entertainer with the left hand over the
outstretched arms of the defender that
was a beautiful play by contagious 81-68
[Music]
we've done by Alan ears Carol just made
it three with 50 seconds remaining in
the game Lakers tonight kuzmic 24 Lonzo
at 19 5 double figures this is a
four-point opportunity for Kentavious
caldwell-pope the Williams picks up the
foul silly foul at this point that's for
sure he got into his face again once he
left his feet the championship Raptors
albeit they've gotten off to their best
start in franchise history it's all
about the postseason and Danny Green has
been in the postseason before with the
aunt waad coos with the assists
three-point opportunity coming to kCPT
so gotta clean that up Jackson with a
rebound lead all day pass stole it away
Green now to pass startled daddy and
Danny Green doing a good job
as soon as he gets it he looks up before
he's got the streak another look at that
play by kcp look pretty cheap spectrum
they don't have to review it in 2016
declared quote I am Toronto and pull
rain from outside not snap the jump shot
need a scratch here definitely need a
scratch here
caldwell-pope is going to attack oh man
you gotta give these guys credit you've
got to give Alvin Gentry Kenny
incredibly he is a great job to get
these guys to play hard beautiful pass
and Danny Green the Raptors back up by
one was it somebody else beside the
Hawks those are the three I remember San
Antonio right correct call woke up again
with rece popgun with the rejection
siakam we're good
grains got 13 excellent decision to
block and check this out it makes that
pass the Danny Green for the three
Raptors by 11 that good well you don't
have to run sets for him he's gonna
create his own up so flaps inside of a
nice pain with you know that the time is
now for this team Eddie green sit up way
up there in serge ibaka actually around
17 this year some of that is the
schedule he played the toughest schedule
in the league about that tas and the
three by caldwell-pope from the corner
[Music]
terrific by Drummond scoops it back up
driving loses it green splash
drills to 300 Drummond does a really
good job guarding the wine lender but he
didn't stay it's moving it's Pete who
shot Contessa I was a big-time shot your
ability to play without it it's probably
the most valuable aspect whether that's
my calculus had such great success
[Applause]
that'll be on the not top tenth place
save that one for Friday not that one
Danny Green with his fifth three-pointer
of the night chance for the break of the
Lakers Thompson now to Rondo you want
with it behind the back he goes to
Caldwell
it could be a four-point play for kcp
going him to the shooter and Bazemore
that time momentum right into the
shooter now the count two baskets in kcp
the Lakers best free throw shooter by
percentage to the line wait back out to
Gasol
Danny Green on the drive doesn't drive
often but got the layup to fall
everything working for Danny Green
tonight strong ridin they close out and
Danny Green little one-handed got away
with it back-to-back double figures here
by Katie behind re Chicago came to town
right here right here because the Lakers
are rolling and it's down to seven and
turnovers to do for you is Casey feeds
the latest with steel and the dome from
point A to point B unbelievable speed
and how about this number Madi
has been holding it back flakes beans
all they're gonna lose it
they could either take it away Kuzma has
12 in the quarter nearly a back fourth
is now it's raw dose caldwell-pope on
its way as for opponents the desperation
Raptors they have solidified the second
spot can they solidify the second
overall best record in the NBA
121 107 is unfortunate but bonded
waiting to check in yeah I said he'll
buy kcp thinks if he's gonna go all the
way so they get one boy welcome back to
the scoring column again tonight to 71
tight nine main rotation today the Nick
here right here beautiful pass by power
[Applause]
butI Jones gorges Jiang has it blocked
by Danny Green who is second among
guards to give it up nice - bouncing it
does CCP's Drive check the whistle on
its way and down it goes k CP goes
baseline draws the defender and wide
open crews over seek I'll try to get
downhill here cuz soul finds green you
love talking about it when you have no
other choice
yeah and deflected by Butler
inside Danny Green close it up and it
may be done Meritage still far in the
game with nine no banana to the side
double digits his caldwell-pope spins it
up and in
Lowry shot clock winding down Green's
got to get it off just does and backs it
all in the frontcourt Lake you two down
104 to 96 on a big night Kimmy is
wearing out the bottom of the net and we
get another look at it look at this
catch and fires I mean the defender
right there but he's so lazy sevens
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
those minute to play here in the first
quarter Alex in charge Danny Green
head fake three-pointer is good and he
greed with three threes here the opening
[Music]
look at that play word kcp goes up for
the jumper and finds Jonathan Lukas call
against Jordan Bell gets it to the paint
against the black back down pull it
loose and able to save it
Danny Green for three Danny Green does
it again look here he just beats him to
the ball saves it and then a desperation
three by Green what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content